now just out of interest because
obviously are very good at driving fast
but do you drive like did you drive here
tonight I didn't do you ever drive I'm
very rarely drive on the park yes you
get at the whole shebang or just the
fast bit no now that we know that you
can't drive no I can't
six and I don't have a driver's license
good to know what do you what how does
it man not have a driving you know some
stage you know when I was when I was you
know when you're sixteen seventeen you
excited to get your driving license so
you don't get your independence you go
out you pick up chicks you go out to the
movies and all those kind of things so
you know you on the bus or would you do
Lewis I get picked up by the chicks
that chick being my mother today yeah
she dragged me here this evening
all right and I started to talk to her
and she was like um she's like no you
you you speak that way first and I'll
speak this way and I come back to you
about this they said that they have
reduced your part in the film to a
non-speaking role